[Musique]
[Rires]
Spider-Man merci beaucoup de sauver ma
vie parce que ma journée démarrait pas
ouf et sa chamboule un peu tout juste
j'en profite de tenir je voulais savoir
si tu étais à jour de ton compte
formation parce que nous on peut te
financer des formations c'est assez cool
donc
un enfant tout seul oh non tu es perdu
[Musique]
mais vas-y papa plonge
ok vous savez qu'il était comique mais
il est aussi plongeur mon père
il prépare les JO
[Musique]
les gars j'ai fait une grosse erreur
pendant notre séjour à Tahiti je me suis
garé dans le parking de l'aéroport
attention
pour combien j'en ai pour 10 jours
c'est moi que ce que je pensais mais ça
reste 310 balles
[Musique]
la personne la plus connue du monde
j'aurais dit la reine d'Angleterre mais
maintenant c'est mort